you have officially crossed the line of
logo decency Hollywood also reads
position if this giant spaceship is
spinning to simulate gravity then why
are all the stars that can be seen out
this window completely stationary also
the CGI of this cockpit is just bad
enough for me to worry that I'm actually
watching Final Fantasy again boring
robotic text continues to give the
audience a tour of the ship even though
we'll get one with Chris Pratt in just a
second that will last 30 minutes also
also I would hope that this ship's
advanced technology that allows it to
conduct interstellar travel would also
allow it to detect an asteroid field and
navigate around it but it seems the ship
is designed to create an inciting
incident for the plot rather than get
its passengers safely to their final
destination it's a tactic the Avalon
learned from United Airlines so this
ship hits a giant iceberg err I mean
asteroid and one random pod hooks up and
decides to wake it's single inhabitant
90 years early you think these ponds
would be controlled together in some way
that would keep just one from going
rogue but if that were true this movie
would be more about how six mechanics
wiped out the Avalon's bar and
complained that the only humanoid robot
looks like Michael Sheen
it's okay James dammit Jim can we agree
that no other intergalactic traveler can
be named Jim also I can believe the
asteroid field causes a series of events
to occur by which Jim spawn was
activated early what I can't believe is
AI that is so amazing it can detect
you'd rather be called Jim than James
but still not know his pod open way too
early you're a passenger on the starship
Avalon seriously why does Jim have no
idea where he is
did someone knock him over the head on
his way to work put him in the starship
against his will you'll enjoy space
travel at its most luxurious that
asteroid hit also screwed up Jim's wake
up video given that he's a lowly
mechanic and only has access to the bare
minimum the ship has to offer these
little Roombas around cleaning even
though no one is set to wake up for 90
years you're adorable illuminate for you
is it so hard to tell him he's in room
268 I mean the illumination thing is
cool if you ever forget but tell him the
number for God's sake hunky lead
character is seen taking a shower with
the water hitting in the back of his
neck cliche so one passenger wakes up
and the entire ship kicks into gear
acting like everyone's awake because the
ship is this is all these extremely
complex AI systems but doesn't have a
clock for it to know that someone is up
early nor does it have the intelligence
to wait for everyone to enter the
auditorium before starting a
presentation
prosperous planet the cradle of
civilization but for many it's also
overpopulated maybe this presentation is
continuing because it's more for us the
viewing audience then for learning group
38 where is everybody we are all on the
starship Avalon this hologram flight
attendant is answering Jim's question
even though he is directed to in the
wrong Tilian please the captain is
usually found on the bridge in the
command ring Jim rightly does not have
access to the bridge but somehow has
access to the command ring which access
requires special authorization so why
did the first door open at all then
reply in 55 years so if they are even
half way from Earth and it still takes
this long to transmit messages then how
would the Avalon be able to communicate
with anyone on earth once they all woke
up in ninety years all the information
would be extremely outdated that will be
six thousand twelve dollars proving that
sending messages from the Avalon is like
present-day Earthlings trying to use
gogo in-flight Wi-Fi I had looked past
the lights coming on when he walks into
a certain area but I after believing
that the humanoid bartender would be
fully functioning ninety years early
this seems like an appliance that would
be taken out of storage and assembled by
a crew member during the month before
all the passengers wake up please make a
selection sorry the mocha cappuccino
extreme is reserved for Gold Class
passengers if he's logging into this
thing with this bracelet then why
doesn't the computer show him only the
drinks to which he has access you mean
people have to play a guessing game to
figure out what coffee they can drink
even though Jim is just a passenger he
has access to the maintenance area can
open all these pods and take replacement
parts
Jim willingly jumps into a pod that
malfunctioned earlier and is closing the
door how does he know what's going to
work how do they know that it won't just
lock him in it does eventually let him
out but this movie is supporting footage
for what I just said would be excellent
at cinema since there isn't a fail-safe
on these paths to keep them from waking
up 90 years early but if you have one
hard enough from the inside it will open
right up since these pods never
malfunction it seems like this wouldn't
be available either it's clear to me now
that the ship is just going to
experience problem after problem until
Jim fixes everything with Jennifer
Lawrence not only saving themselves but
everyone on the ship will go ahead and
add a sin for predictability but this
makes me wonder if a whole bunch of
critical errors happen and there's no
one week to fix them what the ship just
explode and everyone would die why is
the no system for some hyper intelligent
robot like the one they made to serve
drinks to solve any problem that may
arise during the 120 years the ship is
in transit or at least have a way to
wake up a team of crew members that can
fix these issues and give them a way to
go back to sleep it's this level of
design hubris that sunk that
a cruise ship a hundred years ago what
was that thing called even though Jim
prized the door to this luxury suite
open with a crowbar the room comes on
normally and doesn't act like he just
broke in on top of that he has access to
the part of the ship where these luxury
suites are can order at the fancy sushi
bar and can play the dance-off game yet
he can't order a fancy coffee in the
cafeteria beginning to think Chris Pratt
loves dancing so much he's made it a
contractual obligation I'm just
realizing that the first third of this
movie is basically the pilot episode of
the last man on earth but in space not
only is Jim able to suddenly enjoy all
the amenities of the ship upon gaining
access to that room but he also found
that hilarious fake beard to wear I
sympathize with Jim not having human
contact but if he really wanted to
simulate that why not just give Arthur a
hook Jim has magical tears that can
still stream down his face even in
zero-gravity by the with this ship
allowed Jim to get in the airlock
without a suit I wanted Dave dead but
it's still at the courtesy to warn him
about entering the airlock without a
helmet Jennifer Lawrence plays or Lane
rejected names include Jane supernova
Celeste Morningstar and hotbody McNabb
debts searching passenger profiles space
books talking the first day of school at
this school bus took 120 years to get
there funny translation if you were hot
anything you say with good humor is
hilarious say you were trapped on a
desert island and you had the power to
wish somebody there with you why would
you tell this Android bartender the
story what function does it serve other
than for him to later tell Aurora that
Jim did this to her stranding her on
that ship for the rest of her life when
you come to that yep it's pretty simple
the decision is clear do the total wrong
thing and open her pods stranding her on
the ship forever or meet you needs
halfway and leave her alone where she
will wake up 90 years from now with
unexplained white stains on the glass
the ship has and Jim was able to find a
workshop that had some gym equipment in
it also this decision will require a
rocky montage
movie feels the need to have its main
character tell me what he's doing even
though I have the mental faculties to
see and understand what he's doing the
metaphor for what Jim is doing here is
something he wouldn't mention in polite
company I admit the decision makes sense
and I can't say that if I were in the
same position I wouldn't talk myself
into doing something like this movie
will go on to show that it was good that
he did this but can we not be so
results-oriented about the action before
we even know what happens this is pretty
goddamn wrong alternately what if this
movie was from her perspective this is a
horror movie where our fun-loving
protagonist with star-lord and Owen
Grady equity becomes the villain hard to
see him as anything else once you do
that there's the crew the crews in a
secure hibernation room
Jim doesn't answer this question until
they're all the way to the hibernation
room also why does the crew have to be
in a secure room the bridge and the
engine makes sense but what are they
worried about happening to the crew
while everyone is asleep seems like the
only thing this ship prepared for was
this love story between Aurora and Jim
I'll walk you to your cabin after all
there are a lot of ruffians about you
never know we might be lurking around
the corner and waking people out of
hyper sleep early don't tell her Arthur
by not simply lying to the robot and
saying Aurora's pod serendipitously
malfunction just the same as his Jim is
creating a liability for himself how can
there be no way to put someone back into
hibernation what if a pod breaks down no
hibernation pod is malfunctioned and
thousands of interstellar flights so
let's make sure we have no fail safes in
place in case the impossible happens
seriously it's pretty odd that a ship
full of futuristic technology and tons
of other fail-safes is so arrogant about
a top-ten concern also I just realized
this movie is Titanic and 2001 and
wall-e all rolled into one
also if each homestead voyage takes well
over a hundred years and they have done
thousands of flights to quote Palin
Parrish what year is it I guess he
forgot those times he went to the sushi
place when the Mexican restaurant in
order whatever he wanted why even go to
the cafeteria anymore when you have all
these great restaurants or do they have
business hours space travel is
lightyears ahead of where we are today
but Roomba technology has remained
mostly the same I've been awake for
seven days it's excellent that Aurora
favors speech-to-text as her way to
write it allows us to hear her thoughts
and gain an understanding of her mental
and emotional state but despite that
it's still narration and I just can't
help myself why did you do it Aurora
asked a question that nobody asks
without context so the gym will think it
means why did you open up my fucking pod
Jeep do you know how much homestead
company made off its first planet eight
quadrillion dollars they discovered a
planet that so closely resembled earth
to the point that Earthlings could
inhabit it what were the chances there
was no other life there or was this
colony planet discovered by Christopher
Columbus the sixteenth icy zeros on the
homestead company's bottom line for
someone so pessimistic about the
homestead company you'd think she didn't
buy a ticket to travel on one of their
planets chef accountant or midwife
she has to be a midwife there's no way
you didn't even without she's a midwife
we'd be friends Jim just said she's a
midwife right and Aurora is a famous
writer from New York with an even more
famous father let's be honest they would
never know each other you don't even
want to think about it anymore all right
I call time how long did it take her to
give up like two weeks who's the
lovely lady this is Aurora Aurora
special she's been up for a few weeks
and this is the first time she's meeting
Arthur
she couldn't have found him on her own
Jim ran into him on day one space the
one thing I do not need more of wifeless
laughter what about my dress yeah what
about her dress this really asks the
question what about his suit did he put
that thing on while wearing his suit or
did he undress in front of her ah the
mysteries of editing this scene would be
super romantic if it wasn't for that
thing he did it's at this point I
realized I'm watching a horror film
disguised as a romantic comedy disguised
as sci-fi so they started making out in
their space suits stopped to take off
their spacesuits Aurora found a robe on
the way back to their room and then they
started back up again the last two
people in the world who would ever get
together if I got together with Jennifer
Lawrence which I'm not opposed to that
statement may apply but Jim is an
attractive dude so you two getting
together is not that far-fetched
attention you may wish to proceed to a
viewing area considering that everyone
is supposed to be asleep right now why
would the ship make this announcement
but this happened if Jim and Aurora
didn't wake up is this announcement for
the robots I have too many questions
also why would a ship that has an engine
that works in space and can travel at
half the speed of light need to
slingshot around a star speaking of half
the speed of light are curious is a real
star that is 36.7 light-years away from
Earth and if they've been traveling for
about thirty years at half the speed of
light they would only be like 15 ish
light-years away from Earth unless the
Avalon's internal clock is just really
done which is totally possible and
they're 20 years further along than they
think they are there's no way they would
be able to slingshot around Arcturus
because they're nowhere near it these
robots have been programmed with French
accents I will be right back I have
nothing at all in particular to do I'm
just going to the bathroom to look at a
ring I already know I have I just need
to be out of the room when Arthur drops
a huge bomb on you about my pod
tampering activities do ya yes I woke
you up
creeper is revealed as a creeper and yet
that does not stop the movie in its
tracks as it should yes I woke you up
now imagine how powerful that would have
been if we didn't know about it there
was a way for this movie to do it but
then we would have hated a Chris Pratt
character instead of somehow feeling
sorry for him just saying I don't feel
sorry for him here even though the movie
is trying its very best this movie is a
classic case of when a mediocre script
happens two great actors
hey at least her Fitbit is still on and
functioning so she knows how many steps
she's taken since her space boyfriend
woke her up right movie spent so much
time on the boy gets girl boy loses girl
a part of this movie I almost forgot the
ship was falling apart
guess this movie is going to become a
sci-fi movie again for 20 minutes your
sweets control center is rebooting
I know it's deep into the movie now but
I got asked this question the ship is
taking these people to another planet
where they sleep for a hundred twenty
years during the trip so why did they
set up the ship with all the amenities
rec rooms cafeteria nice Suites and so
on wouldn't have just woken up went
through a quick recovery period and
deported or was the plan to wake them up
a year in advance let them enjoy the
ship then drop them off on another
planet because I don't see the reason
either way I hope you finally find
someone who fills your heart and I hope
best friend from 30 years ago in a video
message somehow says just the right
words to turn Aurora slowly back to the
direction of Jim copy please as Arthur
always served coffee and they've just
been going to the cafeteria for coffee
for no reason this is dead so this ship
which has experienced several power
malfunctions randomly awakens one more
person a crew member who can unlock
doors Jim couldn't access before because
this movie basically backed itself into
a corner story wise and needed some
serious Fishburne ex machina also it's
pretty insane with all the different
failures only two pods malfunction when
switch Byrne is here to indicate the
film has reinitiated sci-fi thriller
mode is something wrong with the ship
says the girl whose ex-boyfriend was
awakened 90 years early and was just
covered in cornflakes she knows she
knows how long you all a year still damn
I'm gonna remove a sin for Laurence
Fishburne saying what I feel you're
right Aurora but the drowning man will
always try and drag somebody down with
him so you see your aura you should shut
the hell up and just put yourself in gym
shoes for a change you selfish asshole
this guy gets revived so that just
before he dies Jim can take his keys and
be the hero of the movie
she's dead Jim so we're stranded on a
sinking ship
let's just hope this time there are
enough lifeboats 612 612
how does someone have 612 disorders this
guy apparently has every affliction ever
diagnosed on house and why isn't this
guy dead right now also I found another
problem with the ship the full-body
scanner is duplicating the disorders on
this list even after being slammed onto
the ground both Jim and Aurora
maintained the ability to run down to
engineering our heroes take time to
power down Arthur while he malfunctions
because that's super important right now
can't we wake up some of the crew
they'll take him too long to recover we
don't have that kind of time instead of
waking up crewmembers when Gus was still
alive Jim Aurora and Gus decided they
could fix the ship on their own and now
when they seriously need some help it's
too late to wake anyone up
this giant engineering room they find a
major problem in only the second place
they visit both Jim Nora have arms that
are stronger than the vacuum of space
it's the reactor control computer it
looks like this computer sustained a
fair amount of damage from that meteor
that hit two years ago but after the
meteor hit all the ship errors went away
except for the one on Jim spot is that
because it was the only error that was
important to the plot at the time as
replacement parts for everything and
there are replacement of hibernation
pods outer door non-responsive oh so
it's unresponsive that seems like plain
simple language that an accomplished
writer should understand I open the door
I get clear you blow that fire into
space so you see the movie engineered
our finale by which two people needed to
be awake to save the ship
this means it was a good thing that Jim
opened Aurora's pond because no one else
would have woken up and Gus Mancuso
would have died before he could help so
the movie is now saying Jim's actions
were justified because of this ending
without you I guess almond knocking
around she's been experiencing lately
caused her to forget that Jim woke her
up dooming her to a life of isolation
and space death because he thought she
was hot so touching the metal lever to
open the hatch burns like hell but
touching the metal counter where the
lever lives doesn't burn it all got
small heat shield allows Jim to survive
this Jim survives this also wait was the
engine off during that whole sequence
how was there gravity inside the ship I
started to think gravity has different
more random properties in this corner of
deep space that's probably true but in a
much more transactional way than he
probably means here he's dead Jim
wait patient is dead I'm no computer
doctor but I don't think you can
resuscitate a dead person
post mortem operations require
authorized medical supervision Jim is
dead and could be revived but poor
Mancuso had to die because of his 612
disorders there's no way he remembered
Mancuso's ID number also even though
these computers know who everyone is
they decide that Aurora's the type of
person who looks like Morpheus and
allowed the override
well she resuscitated a dead person
thank you be still why did you revive
him first instead of painting him then
reviving it there's anyone out attack
why there were over 5,000 people on this
ship and they don't have a second auto
doc wouldn't a better reason be someone
has to be outside to initiate it and
from this day forward Aurora I never
thought about the fact that Jim
condemned her to a life where she would
never see another human face and never
breathe fresh air again even though we
can see the planet the Avalon's engines
are still running which leads me to
believe that the ship might just fly
right past homestead
- if someone doesn't wake up and put on
the brakes and if they're close enough
to the planet to see it this size then
why is the crew just now waking up also
why did they hire Andy Garcia to show up
at the end is the captain for two
seconds how much did that cost
all of this foliage was able to flourish
for 88 years without a nearby Sun I'm
just gonna bash your brains
Kevin's log stardate twenty to fifty
nine point 55 guess I am gonna die of
old age on the ship just know that I
will never forget you to help you
recover from hibernation be sure to
drink plenty of fluids I can no longer
sit back and allow the International
communist conspiracy to SAP and in
purified I love our precious bodily
fluids this is Tom he worked in the coal
mine till they closed the town huh it's
Alice came over here from Milan when she
was a baby she lived in an earring most
of her life huh
in the end see she works in the dress
shop makes noises like a chip look when
she gets real excited did you know that
the original name for pac-man was puck
back yeah do you think it was because he
looks like a hockey puck but it actually
comes from the Japanese prints of
Hatfield Haku which means to flash once
past opening closed
[Music]
Aurora Borealis at this time of year at
this time of day in this part of the
country
localized entirely within your kitchen